Alright, Sam. So chatter's cool. I'm into the social
thing, but I want to make this thing mobile.
>> Alright.
>> You promised me that I can.
>> You already did.
>> So I have this thing called an iOS simulator, and it
let's me show you what this would look like on an iPhone.
>> Sweet.
>> And right now it's not that impressive.
It looks like a crappy website on an iPhone.
>> What is this? A website for ants?
>>
[LAUGH]
And that's bad. The main ten ants maybe.
>> No.
[LAUGH]
>> I can zoom in, but still this is kind
of, you know, not that impressive, so what can I do?
>> All right, so you could install an app right off,
you know, the app store into your phone. Or you could just
navigate to a new URL, that will pull up all of
this data and all of your applications in a mobile web app.
>> Okay, what.
>> So.
>> What is this mystery URL?
>> Sales
Force One, yow.
>> Okay.
>> Alright so, don't delete everything, just at the end of this URL, we'll
delete everything back to dot com, so just keep going back.
>> Okay. Yep, and then, there you go and then /one/one.app.
>> w, I mean, o-n-e?
>> Yep.
>> One.app?
>> Oh man, that is cool. Okay.
>> Alright, so first what we're looking
at right now is. That's our chatter feed.
>> Okay.
>> But this whole thing is pulling up SalesForce one, which is.
>> I'm going to like this, sorry.
>> You're going to like your own post?
>> Yeah.
>> Wow.
>> Is it, is it lame?
>> It's okay. It's socially acceptable in the corporate world.
>> Okay.
>> All right, but, what this is, is it's a
mobile representation of all of your Salesforce data in one application.
And so maybe you didn't realize this the whole time we
were going through all of our app building, but you simultaneously
built a mobile app that's completely functional with everything that you've
already done. And you can see its service in a phone.
>> Yeah. That is really cool. So, let me poke around a bit.